one of the really interesting things
we're seeing over the last week
has been this reversal from much of the
republican party
about
the ukraine russia situation and early
you saw a bunch of right wingers
including trump tucker carlson
uh tulsi gabbard who claims to be on the
left but we know she's not um sort of
defend vladimir putin and that did not
go super well a lot of republicans just
weren't buying it because it's
completely implausible that we should be
supporting vladimir putin so now they're
sort of switching to supporting ukraine
and one aspect of this is that now many
people who have been against nato for a
while are switching to talk about how
great nato is and the the sort of most
um notable bullet point about this is
that donald trump is now
taking credit for nato's existence even
though for much of his presidency he
wanted to end nato and get the us out of
it and and just completely take it apart
rolling stone
rolling stones peter wade has a good
piece of this called trump who wanted to
withdraw the us from nato
now claims credit for its existence
there would be no nato if i didn't act
strongly and swiftly the former
president said he put out this statement
or you know it was put out from by his
new spokes relatively new spokeswoman
liz harrington he put this out yesterday
and the statement reads i hope everyone
is able to remember that it was me i
mean it's literally like a little kid it
was me as president of the united states
that got delinquent nato members to
start paying their dues which amounted
to hundreds of billions of dollars
there would be no nato if i didn't act
strongly and swiftly which is a
laughable claim
nato was very strongly in existence
before trump became president there was
no sign nato was going away trump adding
also i mean he trump did everything good
i guess guys
also it was me that got ukraine the very
effective anti-tank buster javelins when
the previous administration was sending
blankets
let history so note now of course
revisionist history is not unusual when
it comes to donald trump and you need
only go back to an article i mean in
this case from january of 2019
from vanity fair by eric lutz
which reported that donald trump
privately discussed destroying
the nato alliance the president
repeatedly told aides that he wanted to
withdraw the united states from the
alliance the new york times reports
trump islam criticized nato frequently
bellyaching that the military
partnership has been unfair to the u.s
and on and on and on however it appears
trump's attacks on nato are more than
bluster
citing senior administration officials
the new york times reported late monday
again this is january 2019 that at
several points in 2018 trump discussed
withdrawing the u.s from the
international organization a move that
would effectively doom the 29 nation
alliance and empower russia which has
spent years seeking to weaken it so
understand the absurdity of this
trump now is taking credit for nato
because nato is so involved in
supporting ukraine against russia what
trump actually was threatening and
thinking of threatening to do and
thinking about doing during his
presidency was pulling out of nato
altogether which would have crippled it
and of course his people will praise the
flip-flop
as the absolute truth and say everybody
else is brainwashed if you don't accept
trump's lies
now remember that this is a common thing
that donald trump does he told people
originally
uh that the vaccine is something he
created and gets credit for it and of
course that's not true
then he played coy with anti-vaxx
talking about freedom and all these
different things and then his supporters
didn't get the vaccine and then he
flipped again and says well i get credit
for it and his supporters they do both
they it they they see
or maybe they don't accept the absurd
contrast and contradiction in trump's
claims about vaccines and yet they don't
care they still support the guy and it's
very similar when it comes to nato and
it's really important to understand
the degree to which this guy is a liar
and so are his followers not only did
trump constantly attack nato which
aligns him with putin remember putin's
one of the big antagonists of nato and
when trump was president he aligned
himself with the antagonists of nato
remember that trump also froze us aid to
ukraine i mean remember the entire
ukraine thing the impeachment and
everything trump wanted dirt on biden
from ukraine
and he initially said we're not giving
them the the aid
until they get me the dirt now
eventually pressure became so great that
trump did have to release that military
aid and now he wants us to believe he's
always been the big defender of nato and
it's actually thanks to him that nato
even exists we all see through it
but unfortunately
many of his followers don't
and that's what i want to talk about
next
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20 percent off monk
packs keto nut and seed bars which taste
just like your favorite sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance
monk pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout